this is a film in which you've had to
balance iconic recordings that most
people around the world have probably
heard playing once or twice with those
required for certain scenes in the film
where you didn't have music could you
talk about the challenge of actually
bringing those two together and creating
what we end up seeing on the screen when
when I first sat on the film it was it
was very early on it was sort of in the
pre-production phase and there was all
sorts of meetings about the script and
about how how the film could be made
because at that stage nobody actually
knew that the script it sort of was
still in it was almost there but just
things were still being changed around a
bit so uncertain scenes would come and
go and you something well how on earth
can we do that you know how how how can
we create that would would it be play
that would be play that back on set or
would rami be up for trying to perform
that or and so we we sort of went
through and worked out but then soon
after that we were told that actually
Queen were completely behind the film
which was which was great news and not
only were they behind the film but we
could go to the studio and and have a
listen through all their material and
see what we could use for the film so
obviously that was a that was a good day
at work to go to Queen's studio and
listen to all their multi-tracks and see
what we could use it became apparent
that actually they have a huge archive
they've been they've been multitrack
recording their sort of concert since
since the beginning of time really since
they started out they'd got recordings
from 1974 that was 16 track recordings
that this sounded great that sounded
really good so so that was a good start
not only did they have that but they
also had you know many would say okay we
need a version a live version of cute
self alive and they say okay well we
have about 22 versions of that which one
do you want and so then it sort of
became down tomorrow point of say well
which one would you like to be in the
film
and so that that was obviously once we
knew that they were behind us that that
did make things a lot easier and then
yeah then we started mapping
out what what recorders we have what we
didn't have and then how we could do the
film from there and I could be wrong in
this but I read somewhere that there was
a degree of manipulation of the actual
existing recordings in order to sort of
ensure the Grammy didn't send that
different yeah
well that that was one of the issues was
because obviously that there were scenes
in the film where we knew that there's
no way there's a Freddie Mercury
recording exists of that scene so that
would need to be created and then with
discussions were well should that should
the the is Romney gonna have a girl
should we get someone that sounds like
Freddie and that's where we got a
Freddie sound like to sort of help out
on some of those scenes as well but then
we sort of thinking but then that's
three people I don't know if there's
ever been a lead character in a film
before let's have three people doing
their voice so that's when myself and
Nina started talking about different
ways of how we could try and make this
these three three different voices one
one person so yeah you want to speak
about basically we used Freddy obviously
as much as we could in the film Rama did
such an amazing job
recreating the physicality and the
performance of Freddy and holding the
audience in his hand on stage as all the
way through the film so we wanted to use
Freddy's voices as much as we could but
obviously it always needed to feel like
it was coming out of Rama's mouth I mean
and essentially what we're doing which
is something that it's quite difficult
in sound he's kind of dead with a voice
you know you reversing your main
character at least while they're singing
so it was very important to us that we
made that feel as authentic and real as
possible in order to do that we recorded
obviously ronnie was singing for his
life on on stage every time he was
performing particularly through Live Aid
and obviously the other concerts in the
film but so we had all the recordings of
that and we also got Romney into gold
Creston Abbey Road and had him recording
all manner of kind of breaths and lip
smacks and inhales and mic blows and all
those kind of things and it was just it
was very detailed editing really - to
get to use little pieces of rami
in-between the song vocals and make sure
they blended together and all felt like
one cohesive voice coming out of Rama's
mouth on stage and and kept because it
was just so crucial point particularly
during live aid of such a long sequence
- that you never ever felt that pushed
away from him you always felt like his
performance was building through and
that was Ronnie singing as Freddy he
wrongly done such an amazing job with
the physicality of it all so we just
needed to do the same with his voice
really
[Music]
[Music]